[Musique]
je vais vous parler de câbles de
télécommunication
j'essaie du coup dit comme ça c'est pas
très sexy mais sachez que sont ces
câbles il n'y aurait pas l'internet
qu'on connaît aujourd'hui
vous avez sûrement tous entendu parler
du cloud cette fameuse entité virtuelle
vaporeuse dans laquelle toutes nos
données numériques y habitent
et bien ce cloud c'est internet
en fait ce n'est juste que des serveurs
reliés entre eux par des fils et quand
ses fils doivent relier des continents
ses fils ce sont les câbles de
télécommunication des câbles sous-marins
posé au fond de la mer dans la boue
savez dit c'est pas très sexy mais
encore une fois sans ces câbles pas
d'internet
donc ça vaut bien la peine qu'on en
parle un petit peu de ces câbles et ça
fait un bon moment qu'on en pose des
câbles au fond de la mer le premier
câble sous marin
il a été posé pour la télégraphie
c'était en 1850 et c'était entre la
france et l'angleterre
c'était un gros câble en cuivre il a
duré que quelques heures
il a transmis quelques messages et il
pouvait transmettre jusqu'à 12 mots par
minute
un câble moderne
c'est un câble qui va avoir une durée de
vie de 25 ans qui peut transmettre
jusqu'à plusieurs dizaines de tera
octets par seconde
vous donner une idée c'est plusieurs
disques durs transmis en une seconde et
un câble moderne
aujourd'hui ça ressemble à ça c'est pas
très gros c'est pas plus gros qu'un
tuyau d'arrosage
c'est un câble en métal recouvert de
plastique et au milieu de ce câble il ya
des fibres optiques et ses fibres
optiques
elles peuvent transmettre des quantités
phénoménales d'information sous la forme
d'impulsions lumineuses et comme ces
impulsions lumineuses vont très vite
dans le câble l'information peut
traverser des océans entier en quelques
millisecondes
c'est comme ça qu'on peut voir en
streaming des vidéos d excellente vidéo
qui sont stockées sur des serveurs à
l'autre bout de la planète
on estime que 95 % du trafic internet
mondial se fait par ces câbles de
télécommunication posé au fond des
océans
il y en a 1 million de kilomètres qui
est posée au fond des océans 1 million
km c'est assez pour faire 25 fois le
tour de la terre je vous parle de câbles
de télécommunication mais en fait c'est
pas du tout mon domaine moi je suis
océanographe
je suis les chercheurs et ingénieurs et
mon domaine c'est l'océanographie
physique c'est l'étude des courants des
vagues des marais du niveau de la mer et
des phénomènes exceptionnels comme les
tsunamis est ma spécialité dans ce
domaine c'est l'observation
parce que dans l'océan c'est souvent en
l'observant qu'on comprend mais l'océan
ses vastes c'est très profond plus de
4000 mètres en moyenne et il se passe
plein de choses
donc si on veut comprendre ce qui s'y
passe il faut pouvoir allait mesurer au
bon endroit au bon moment
même si finalement ce qu'on mesure c'est
des paramètres simples comme la
température ou la pression est
aujourd'hui mesurer la température ces
critiques dans le cadre du changement
climatique à cause de nos émissions de
gaz à effet de serre on observe un
réchauffement global de la planète et de
ses océans et pour observer ce
réchauffement des océans
on a plusieurs outils on a des
satellites qui tournent en permanence
autour de la planète et qui eux vont
mesurer la surface la température à la
surface des océans
on a des flotteurs et des navires
océanographiques qui vont mesurer de
temps en temps la température au milieu
de l'océan mais on a très peu de données
au fond de l'océan dans l'océan mesure
aussi la pression est ce que quand on
mesure la pression au fond de l'océan
en fait on mesure le poids de l'eau et
le poids de l'eau il nous renseigne sur
le niveau de la mer et dans le cadre du
changement climatique et bien au niveau
de la mairie monte il monte parce que
les océans se réchauffent
donc ils prennent plus de place et le
niveau de la mer il monte parce qu'il ya
plus d'eau dans les océans à cause de la
fonte des glaciers si on mesurait la
pression au fond des océans en fait on
comprendrait mieux où et comment la mer
monte
et puis aussi les tsunamis les tsunamis
sont des vagues particulière quand elles
sont au large dans l'océan profond
elles sont toutes petites mais elles
vont très vite c'est quand elle arrive à
la côte qu'elle ralentisse et qu'elle
peut devenir très grande et aujourd'hui
on mesure les tsunamis mais quand ils
sont déjà à la côte
si seulement on arrivait à mesurer les
tsunamis au large avant qu'ils arrivent
on aurait des prévisions plus fiables et
plus rapidement mais on sait comment
faire pour mesurer le tsunami au large
mais on ne le fait pas parce que c'est
avec des systèmes qui sont si chers que
c'est pas possible
vous l'aurez compris il nous manque
beaucoup donné au fond des océans et du
coup vous dit peut-être aussi est-ce
qu'on ne pourrait pas profiter des
centaines de milliers de kilomètres de
câbles qui sont posés au fond des océans
et bien non on ne peut pas en profiter
parce qu'aujourd'hui ces câbles sont
sourds et aveugles à leur environnement
il ya peut-être une solution tout à
l'heure je vous parlais des impulsions
lumineuses qui voyagent dans les fibres
optiques des câbles et bien ces fibres
ces impulsions lumineuses quand elle
voyage elle se fatigue et il faut leur
redonner de l'énergie tous les cinquante
à deux cents kilomètres dans des
amplificateurs qu'on appelle des
répéteurs dans ces répéteurs les
impulsions lumineuses fatigué arrivent
elles sont ré amplifié puis elles sont
renvoyées vers le prochain à petter et
ainsi de suite pour pouvoir traverser
des océans entier ces répéteurs ont
accès à la fibre et ils sont alimentés
en électricité par le câble l'idée
paraît donc simple on pourrait installer
des capteurs de température et de
pression dans les répéteurs des câbles
de télécommunications il serait alimenté
en électricité par le câble et il
transmettra leurs données dans les
fibres optiques
on pourrait ainsi couvrir la majorité
des océans et on pourrait répondre à des
questions sociétales importantes comme
le réchauffement climatique
la montée du niveau de la mer la
prévention des catastrophes naturelles
pour les tsunamis par exemple quand un
tsunami arrive il est trop tard pour
protéger les installations et par contre
on peut mettre la population à l'abri
et quand on parle d'évacuation avoir un
tsunami
chaque minute compte pour pouvoir sauver
des vies et on a déjà montré que si on
avait des capteurs de pression large on
pourrait donner l'alerté jusqu'à 25 %
plus vite
l'idée paraît donc séduisante mais il ya
de nombreux obstacles
il ya des obstacles d'ordre
technologique des obstacles juridiques
et des obstacles financiers en termes
technologiques
les capteurs de température et de
pression sont des instruments très
fragile donc avant de pouvoir les mettre
dans les répéteurs il faut qu'ils
puissent encaisser
le traitement violent qui est subie par
les répéteurs quand ils sont posés au
fond de la mer par les navires
spécialisés et croyez-moi ce traitement
est très violent rien à voir avec la
façon dont nous océanographe
on traite ces instruments nous nous les
traitons comme des vases en cristal on
les transporte dans des écrins en mousse
on les dépose délicatement au fond de la
mer en termes juridiques les câbles de
télécommunications sont très protégés
dans le cadre de la convention des
nations unies sur le droit de la mer
plus protégés encore que les systèmes de
mesure de l'océan je sais ça paraît
bizarre mais c'est un des plus gros
obstacles
si jamais on mettait des capteurs sur
les câbles les caps perdrait une partie
de leur protection juridique et il y a
évidemment des obstacles financiers
parce que les opérateurs ou les
propriétaires de câbles eux ne tirait
aucun bénéfice commercial de
l'installation de capteurs sur leurs
câbles mais les choses avancent depuis
2012 c'est un petit groupe de
scientifiques du juriste et
d'industriels qui cherchent et qui
trouvent des solutions à ces obstacles
les constructeurs fabriquent des
capteurs qui sont plus résistants des
accords internationaux sont signés entre
les pays pour pouvoir échanger librement
les données scientifiques et des
bailleurs de fonds potentiels ont été
identifiés
la prochaine étape est de faciliter la
pose du premier câble intelligent ce
premier câble intelligent servira de
démonstrateur et montrera l'utilité et
la faisabilité de ces câbles intelligent
idéalement ce sera un câble entre deux
pays ou deux il seulement et avec
l'essor d'internet des nouveaux câbles
sont posés tous les ans dans le monde
est-ce que le premier câble intelligent
sera posée dans le pacifique
je ne sais pas mais je suis convaincu
d'une chose c'est que quand ça sera fait
on se dira mais pourquoi on n'a pas fait
un grand merci
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]